[музика]
всім привіт я саша купу гайди тя чого
листи знайти
розповім треш кіпр особини і вона народилася
разом умань черкаської області
висота я любила шоу детства особи його
в маман їх тато рак-то на шпалерах
за рахунок янкул і зажадала виду
інших вона потім я виросла і вступив на
дузі невського національного
лінгвістичного університету вінчала
англійську чи іспанську мови хоче ризики
вам розповісти ще б вся патча лося
чому я патчу лапи сад і
коли моєму синові було висимо довіряти
руки вин дуже полюблю вч і that is
actively вік я нехай одного дня
when money прожили всі у нас мало у
жертви верхніх вінду жеребкування татамі
зграйка
jerome форель джеффа кінні я задумав
ася чого плюс пробувати і написати таку
книгу money
і я написала повість сім'я складів
говоруха в ній і дати а про хлопчика
android
я кому однокласниця дівка пророкувала
оштен exim на складах вся шана куна
вірити йди про споріднення, а закони патина
ще дня вживати у різанину ми одні
холод це замислюється як android
виплутається знак у вигляді знає eset
прочитав тюк niva все маленька киева
знай дати з пологами нам про ливан мною
андрей то його kid monster monster травня
дуже капський характер займається
йогою у так і кит девак а також ось він
ще ви можете допомогти цьому малюнку
називається колу a big car потоку
природі у школі ви пізнаємо це зі збоєм
нові ми розповімо за історію про бабусю
яко повернулася аурі дна соло писати
чорнобильської катастрофи
ви нашого самого пенсії по сир і 2 su
una дядько онука марійка якосч уроку
проїжджаючи в гості я зачитаю вам біля ривка
всім у ривку марика тикають про що вже
бабуся ви вирішувала повернути iso шкідлива
сулу чому ви на божа ж це разом
знаю це згинати ми попали раз навіки
я проїжджаю в гості ми не час тиші
можна б радіація у zeidan частоти
але зі шкіряною вставали бабуся показу
там вони свої господарство ягоди та гриби
і фрукти овочі як пара power that і
сяду дому, а я синовіт з бабусь іншим
Ісусе доміно познайомилася з у седана
бабу не називали відьмою div лисиць у gif
лосів такий всю машкович уліссе
я б вирішила написати про в'янення після
того, як побувала біля чорнобильської зони
козами гілки давай від нас покинутих сил
ні показав нам ходинку у я кидав за годину
жила бабуся одні сенью на сосал у
дуна проїжджав і удачі могли бачити і
поїхати зжиті в місця
али бабуся видно волосся їй було добре
автобус чи давно народилося а вся
історія так у разовому вона і на дихнула
ще я написала лупа вигляду її на не дуже
отвір на 7 you творчості пізно
є did йому найкращі школи
с одягайся в полюбить а моїх героїв так
самоціллю як люблю їх я тикового вам
літературного віднімання